our study of the genealogy of morals is
now coming to them with this fourth
video the second one in which we're
going to look at the longest essay the
third essay which is about aesthetic
ideals and in the last one I began from
this vantage point with this tripartite
distinction this three-part drama
between the warrior the priest and the
herd the mass the common people and we
talked about different ways in which
this drama works out we're going to come
back to that in just a moment we also
talked about different types of people
who would be tempted by aesthetic ideals
and we saw that the artist really
doesn't have that much to do with the
aesthetic ideal in a certain way once
the artist adopts the aesthetic ideal
they cease doing art fully in the sense
that Nietzsche envisions the philosopher
though fits the aesthetic ideal quite
well there's another type that fits it
even better and that is what he calls
the priest then we're going to see a
fourth type that we could talk about
later on and that would be the person of
science the person who is committed to a
scientific worldview but who really
hasn't left behind the aesthetic ideal
and that's where the book is actually
been to more or less end so that's where
we're headed I want to put all this back
up on the board again as a starting
point so we can remind ourselves of the
dynamic that that's in place we're going
to come back to this in just a moment
after making a detour
soon after after
going through this so the original
evaluation that we have is that which is
provided by the warrior class the
powerful the strong those who are noble
who are noble precisely because they
make themselves to be Noble they impose
their will upon others they are
effective Paragons or exemplars of the
will to power at a certain point they're
also relatively simple and as far as the
human animal goes in a certain respect
they represent an early stage they don't
represent the full complexity that's
possible for the kind of animal that we
are that is actually represented more by
the priests who originally is coming
from this same aristocratic strata that
has imposed its rule upon a bunch of
commoners and not only impose its rule
imposed its valuation of things but the
priest is different the priest is a new
type with the priest comes that the
possibility is something greater
something deeper something as Nietzsche
will say more complex but also in a
certain respect sick life no longer just
exuberantly imposing itself upon their
life but turning itself in word and
turning itself also against the life
which is which is so exuberant turning
itself against the warrior and finding
new possibilities plumbing new deaths
opening up the space of a soul as he
talks about it then we have the heard
the ordinary people the ones who are
imposed upon they don't create values
according to nature the priest creates
new values new evaluations the herd
don't like being imposed upon but they
don't do anything about it successfully
the only times that they actually rise
up is not as individuals but as a mass
together provoked by resultant against
the the upper
and generally they only do so when
they've got the driving force and
organizing force of the priests actually
assisting them so that's where we start
this is a common thematic in Nietzsche's
work
we live in an epoch according to
Nietzsche which is dominated by these
figures and these figures have
fundamentally misunderstood who and what
they are and what it means to be human
we have left behind a period that was
dominated by this but Nietzsche is not
suggesting simply a return to this if
you bring up the term that it doesn't
actually use in this book the uber match
the Superman the over man the superior
human being the one who transcends
humanity and thereby realizes humanity
you won't actually find that individual
in this schema and we'll see the hints
of you know where that would come about
a little bit later on so why have we
brought all this back up at the start we
ended by talking about philosophers and
touching on priests well in section 10
he tells us that philosophers have
always had to from the very beginning
sort of ally themselves with and placed
themselves under the rubric of the
priestly type the contemplative type the
one who withdraws from rule from reality
all the more to dominate that in in
return so he says the philosophical
spirit always had to use as a mask and a
cocoon the previously established types
the previously established types of the
contemplative type would be the priest
so he says the priest the sorcerer the
soothsayer in any case a religious type
somebody who is having traffic with some
sort of transcendent dimension and you
know it's interesting too because if you
read Diogenes Liara takes lives the
Philosopher's who does he actually begin
with he begins with rule
types talking about about some of them
so he says in order to be able to exist
at all the ascetic ideal for a long time
serve the philosophers a form in which
to appear as a precondition of existence
he had to represent it so is able to be
a philosopher he had to believe in it in
order to be able to represent it the
peculiar withdrawn attitude of the
philosopher world denying hostile to
life suspicious of the senses freed from
sensuality which has been maintained
down to the most modern times and has
become virtually the philosophers pose
practice laws which is the again the
aesthetic ideal withdrawing from the
purely animal our instincts our drives
all that sort of stuff is above all a
result of the emergency conditions
Nietzsche says under which philosophy
arose and survived at all
so the ascetic priest provided until the
most modern times the repulsive and
gloomy caterpillar for me says in which
alone the philosopher could live and
creep about so you know is this is this
true I mean we have some exceptions
through through time like for instance
the epicurean tradition which you know
you see maybe now that the Cure is so
much he's just saying well the gods are
largely irrelevant to us but Lucretius
makes Epicurus into a kind of hero but
really that only comes about within a
certain kind of framework once religion
has already sort of had the wind taken
out of its sails and it's interesting
that in many religious texts Epicureans
are sort of the code word for atheists
for those who not only don't fit in but
represent only a small tiny elite not
really part of the general culture until
till modernity so he says only now that
we behold the ascetic priests do we
seriously come to grips with our problem
so what is our problem what is the
meaning of the aesthetic ideal only now
does it become serious we are now
face-to-face with the actual
representative of seriousness what is
the meaning of seriousness it's even
more fundamental questioning so
maybe perhaps trembling on our lips at
the point so he says the idea at issue
here is the valuation which the ascetic
priests pray places on our life he
juxtaposes it along with what pertains
to it nature world the whole sphere of
becoming a transitoriness with a
different mode of existence which it
opposes and excludes unless it turn
against itself deny itself in that case
the case of the ascetic life life counts
as a bridge to that other mode of
existence so I'm going to actually now
erase some of this schema so we can
think about this this case of the priest
so the priest is giving us a framework
in which we have two kinds of worlds we
have our experienced world which is one
transitory
in the perfect the world becoming nature
and then we have the other world like he
says the different mode of existence the
higher which is more real you might
think of this in terms of plato's to
world hypothesis into the world of the
forms the ideals on this muddy mucky
material world in which the forms are at
best represented very imperfectly as
copies or copies of copies or copies of
copies of copies and we can keep on
going in from that so the priest says
look you've got these two things two
different modes of existence and this
one only has value if it is made into a
bridge a place of process leading to
this this higher world so you can take
the material world and you can give it
some value if and only if you make it a
place in which these higher things are
going to be realized and that itself is
done through asceticism so he says what
does this mean so monstrous a motive al
uation saying that stands inscribed in
the history of mankind and here's a very
important point
not as an exception in curiosity but one
of the most widespread and enduring of
all phenomena so Nietzsche is saying
this isn't just happening in Western
culture this happens in every culture
that developed to a certain point
every culture in which you have somebody
who emerges and starts to actually have
some some dynamism some so we purchase
some some gripping points who is
different than the Warriors who are
imposing their rule different from the
herd who is just you know sort of stuck
with it and kind of grumbles a bit under
it and says there's more to life than
what's been realized here this happens
in Japanese culture and Arabic culture
you know you can run through whatever
you want for him so he says consider how
regularly and universally the ascetic
priest appears in almost every age he
belongs to no one race he prospers
everywhere he emerges from every class
of society
so this ascetic priest this problematic
of setting up the better but ideal world
against the worse but real world this
occurs over and over and over again
throughout history societies cultures he
says nor does he breed and propagate his
mold motive al uation through heredity
the opposite is the case broadly
speaking a profound instinct rather
forbids them to propagate so this is
something that's communicated not just
through culture you know in the sense of
like you know reproduction but through
ideals through ideas that can be grasped
can be transported from culture to
culture and he says here it must be a
necessity of the first order that again
and again promotes the growth and
prosperity of this life inimical
inimical species an enemy to life it
must indeed be in the interest of life
itself
that such a self-contradictory type does
not die out now where is life actually
this is life
but this also is life this is something
that's ideal but it is also something
that life generates so as to be able to
critique itself to be able to criticize
itself to be able to turn against itself
life itself is so contradictory so
malleable that it produces out of its
own plenitude that which goes against it
he says an ascetic life itself is a
self-contradiction here rules a result
amount without equal that of an
insatiable instinct and power will that
wants to become master not over
something in life the the warrior wants
to become a master of something in life
other warriors when they clash the herd
they want things they want to impose but
their wants and demands are local even
if they want to have a world empire they
just want to be the top dog in all of
the world the priests nature says wants
to dominate life itself a will to power
that wants to become master not over
something in life but over life itself
over its most profound powerful and
basic conditions an attempt is made to
employ force to block up the wells of
force
here's psychophysiological well-being
itself is viewed askance and especially
the outward expression of this
well-being beauty and joy while pleasure
is felt and sought there's still
pleasure being looked for in ill
constituted Nestico pain mischance
ugliness voluntary deprivation
self-mortification self flagellation
self-sacrifice and he says all of this
is in the highest degree paradoxical so
the priest the priest is in fact a
paradox a complicated configuration of
things that seems to go against
everything that we would we would think
it doesn't seem
make sense now for a philosopher when
something doesn't make sense what do you
do you dig in deeper you start thinking
about it more and here we have an
interesting thing to look at Nietzsche
in Section 12 is actually revealing to
us a really important thing about his
method so he says suppose such an
incarnate will the contradiction and
anti naturalness is induced to
philosophize so let's say the priest
this paradoxical priest philosophizes
upon what will it invent its up mole
innermost contrariness upon what is felt
most certainly to be real and actual it
will critique the real and the actual it
will look for error precisely where the
instinct of life most unconditionally
pauses truth you will for example he
says like the aesthetics of the Vedanta
philosophy does an Indian you know
Orthodox Indian philosophy downgrade
physicality to an illusion likewise pain
multiplicity the entire conceptual
antithesis subjective object errors
nothing but errors so philosophy by
working in the realm of the idea will
actually banished or at least claim to
banish these things that are real why
does it do that here we're getting to
something that's really important
the paradox is made explicable if we
understand things in terms of pleasure
he says to renounce belief in what in
one's ego to deny one's reality what a
triumph not merely over the senses over
appearance but a much higher kind of
triumph a violation and cruelty against
reason a voluptuous pleasure that
reaches a type when the ascetics
self-contempt and self mockery of Reason
declares there's a realm of truth and
being but reason is excluded from it so
what is the aesthetic doing they're
using the most complex the most
adaptable of the human faculties to
generate a paradox going beyond reason
that paradox is not only something that
they're generating it's in that it's
part of what's going on in their drives
the priest is in a certain respect sort
of like at the very crux of life itself
which is contradictory and paradoxical
for Nietzsche so he says that we're
actually getting somewhere now he says
if we want knowledge if we're going to
be philosophers let's not be ungrateful
to such resolute reversals of accustomed
perspectives and valuations to see
differently in this way for once to want
to see differently is no small
discipline that's one of the things the
philosopher does to want to see
differently to want to reverse things to
change things to see can this work and
this makes sense and he says we have two
different ways we can look at this the
philosopher
to do some more aeration the philosopher
and the priest and actually the man of
science they want to be objective they
want a truth that is impersonal that is
not committed that could be the same for
everybody across the board the idea is
the hallmark of truth for for many
people
so he says objectivity what is
objectivity is it understood as
contemplation without interest is it
disinterested does it have to detach
itself from self from the individual
from their actual conditions he says no
it's the ability to control one's pro
and con and just dispose of them so one
knows how to employ a variety of
perspectives and effective
interpretations in the service of
knowledge the very interesting idea so
instead of having objectivity and
personal disinterested and basically
just one perspective no effects or
feelings being involved what's the
alternative
CEL dominates and makes use of many
perspectives multiple effects like it
says the self controls ones pros and con
and disposes them one knows how to
employ a variety of perspectives one
looks at things from a number of
different angles not just one single one
and effective interpretations in the
service of knowledge and he says let's
be on guard against the dangerous old
conceptual fiction that posited a pure
will list painless timeless knowing
subject let us guard against the snares
of such contradictory concepts as pure
reason with it which would be over here
absolute spirituality there's Hegel
absolute spirit knowledge in itself
these always demand that we should think
of an eye that is completely unthinkable
and I turned in no particular direction
in which the active and interpreting
forces through which alone seeing become
seeing something this stuff over here
are supposed to be lacking
that's a nuts nonsense he says there is
only a perspective seeing only a
perspective knowing the more effects we
allow to speak about one thing the more
eyes different eyes
we can use to observe one thing the more
complete will our concept of this thing
our objectivity be so Nietzsche is
saying if we actually want genuine
objectivity it's not over here in the
impersonal this is where objectivity
lies and it's by forming a kind of
visit view of things that are
perspectives and effective
interpretations feeling interpretations
desired interpretations that may not
actually all jive together but can be
forced into at least juxtaposition with
each other
that's Nietzsche's method that's what
he's advocating that's what it would
mean to follow and yet just footsteps
here so let's go on and let's go back to
talking about the priest the herd the
warrior so he says and this is in
Section 13 what are we concerned with
this ideal how did this ideal acquire
such power Howard it rule over people he
says it ruled over men as imperiously as
we find a history especially where the
civilization and taming a man has been
carried through and it expresses a great
fact it was a very important point the
Sikh leanness of the type of man we have
hitherto or at least of the tamed man on
the physiological struggle of man
against death or more precisely against
disgust with life against exhaustion
against desire for the end so where is
this Center it's centered on the priest
but the priest is that himself sick the
herd is also sick and the priest will
actually make even the warrior sick in
return so the priest is going to end up
in culture as Nietzsche is seeing it
here the priest is going to end up in
the higher position
we're at least on the same level as the
warrior and the herd will I belong
and what's going to happen with this
well he's talking about this sick
leanness and it continues in chapter 14
he says the more normal sick leanness
becomes among men the higher should be
the honor accorded to rare cases of
great soul and body man's lucky hits
that would be the warrior right the ones
who are able to sort of assert
themselves they have that's sort of they
don't know where they get it from it's
just kind of luck in the draw but they
have that power that dynamism he says is
this what we do to record great honour
to them says the sick represent the
greatest danger for the healthy it's not
the strongest but the weakest whose
spell disaster for the strong is this no
this is broadly speaking it's not fear
of man that we should desire to see
diminished this fear compels the strong
to be strong if you have somebody to
match yourself against who is healthy
who actually has you know drives effects
that are that are fairly simple
straightforward directional you can
clash with them they can be your rival
they can become your friend they can
become your enemy there's all sorts of
possibilities for sort of genuine
authentic engagement with them not so
with the herd not so with the priest
though he says what is more to be feared
is that man should not inspire profound
fear but profound profound nausea nausea
sickness and he says not only not also
not great fear but great pity he says
suppose the two were one day through
night they would inevitably beget one of
the uncanny Ahsan stirs the last will of
man is will to nothingness needless when
our picture of human beings no longer is
motivated by looking to the strong maybe
I should get rid of the word warrior
here and we should
think in terms of the strong because the
warrior could be somebody in politics
the warrior could be somebody in
artistic culture who says screw you I'm
going to do what I what I want with
these materials and if you don't like it
too bad because that's what I'm doing
and maybe they actually succeed on the
basis of that it could be somebody even
in fashion perhaps it could be somebody
in business it could be all sorts of
things but the strong are able to stick
by themselves and say I am going to
follow through on this I am going to
impose my good versus other people's bad
if instead we are thinking in terms of
the herd and in terms of the valuation
of the priests gives then we're at risk
instead of having fear when looking to
these kind of individuals but having
pity and feeling this kind of sickness
so he says the sicker man's greatest
danger not the evil not to be supplied
prey not the exploiters not the tough
guys not the ones who are able to impose
their will the sick or the greatest
danger those who are failures from the
start downtrodden crushed it is they the
weakest who must undermine life among
men who call into question and poison
most dangerously our trust in life in
man in and ourselves where does one not
encounter that veiled glance which
burdens one with a profound sadness that
in return glance of the born failure
which betrays how much a man speaks to
himself that glance which is a sigh
beautiful passenger a glance which is a
sigh the person who feels bad for
themselves they feel that they've gotten
the you know bad into the stick they've
gotten a raw deal only things have been
different
they would have been such a great person
but they didn't make it happen and
they're not going to make it happen he
says it is on such soil swampy ground
that every weed every poisonous plant
grows always so small so hidden so fall
so saccharine here are the worms of
vengeance vengefulness and rancor swarm
here the air stinks of secrets and
concealment here the web of the most
malicious of all conspiracies is being
spun constant constantly the conspiracy
of the suffering against the well
constituted in victorious here the
aspect of the victorious is hated the
herd hates the successful hates the
powerful and what mendacious 'no s'what
lying abilities is employed to disguise
that this hatred is hatred so that's
part of what's going on with Roseann
Tamara's on Timon has its origin in sort
of being pushed into the lower position
and having to take it and hating that
and reacting against that but not being
able to express that directly and having
to conceal it and having to make it as
we say passive aggressive having to make
it become you know a little bit less
overt and it with time that starts to
become part of one's being part of one's
character there can be entire cultures
and institutions of results and month
going on so he says what do they really
want what do the lowest want at least to
represent justice love wisdom
superiority they also have a will to
power they also want to dominate and the
only way that they can dominate is by
making the strong feel and look bad and
thereby sort of elevating themselves in
their mind above them he says and how
skillful such an ambition makes them
admire above all the forgers skill with
which a stamp of virtue even the ring
the golden sounding ring of virtue is
here counterfeited they monopolized
virtue these weak hopelessly sick people
there is no doubt about it
we are we alone are the good enjoy
say we alone are the Pullman is
benevolent honestly the men of goodwill
they walk among us as embodied
reproaches as warnings to us as if
health while constituted as strength
pride in the sense of power were
necessarily vicious things so what's
going out of yours is a transvaluation
of values that where the herd is trying
to place itself above the strong but it
does so because of the priest because of
the ascetic ideal that's going on talks
about the will of the weak to represent
some some form of superiority their
instinct for devious paths to tyranny
over the healthy and he says this goes
on everywhere examine the background of
every family every organization every
Commonwealth everywhere the struggle of
the sick against the healthy a silent
struggle as a rule with petty poisons
with pinpricks with sly long-suffering
expressions he goes on he gives a lot of
examples I'm actually gonna skip over
these now he labels this result in mobs
and result amount means a number of
different things for nature we're
actually not gonna have time to cover
all the different modalities of that
here I'll see if I can do that a core
concept video down the line the point is
there's a kind of concealment of what
one is really feeling what one is really
expressing and the way in which results
amount works is by denigrating something
that has genuine value and try to pull
it down and thereby pull oneself up so
now he goes on and he talks a little bit
more about the danger here he says no
greater or more calamitous
misunderstanding as it is possible than
for the happy the well constituted
powerful and soul and body to begin to
doubt their right to happiness so when
the strong when the people who break the
mold when the people who go their own
way are actually starting to believe
this and feel like maybe I'm doing the
wrong thing maybe I should respect
everybody
right maybe everybody does they actually
have rights rather than that people have
rights if they can actually defend that
more they can impose them when they
start to believe that then we have a
problem he says then they begin to doubt
their right to happiness and he says if
this happens the healthy should be
segregated from the sick but how can
that happen how can we make that that
take place so the higher ought not to
degrade itself to the status of an
instrument of the lower the pathos of
distance ought to keep their tasks
eternally separate their right to exist
the privilege of the full tone Bell over
the false in the craft is a hundred
times a thousand times greater they
alone are warranty for the future they
alone are liable for the future of man
the sick are not the future of human
beings but what can we do who's going to
take care of the sick are the healthy
going to take care of the sick if they
do that they're going to become sick if
they like Nietzsche says if they degrade
themselves to the status of an
instruments of the lower they become
lower they become infected so he says if
you've grasped this in all its
profundity you've also grasped one
further necessity the necessity of
doctors and nurses who are themselves
sick who are the doctors and nurses
the priest the priestly class those who
fit the priestly type and now we notice
too this is not just priests this is
also the majority of philosophers even
certain artists if they are you know
forgetting what it means to be an artist
and we're going to also see men of
science where you know scientists those
who are committed to a sort of
scientific naturalistic in a sort of
banal sense worldview so he says we must
count the ascetic priest as the
predestined Savior shepherd and advocate
of the sick herd that's his mission he
has to be sick himself how else would he
understand the sick he must also be at
the same time strong master of himself
even more of others with his will to
power intact so as to be both trusted
and feared by the sick so as to be their
support so there has to be a distance
between the priest and the heard the
priest cannot simply be of the herd
cannot just be their representative he
has to actually exert power on them
shape them direct them form them and he
says um the priest is having a war with
the beasts of prey a war of cutting
rather than one of force so he's
fighting with them but he also is
defending them again he's defending the
herd against the strong as well but he's
not just defending the herd against the
strong here's a really interesting point
Nietzsche says he defends his sick herd
against itself against the baseness
spite malice and whatever else is
natural to the to the ailing and sick
and smoulders within the herd itself
what does he mean there again rosante
mom's the priest is helping to redirect
or staunch the flow or or hem up this
current of rosante law that flows not
only within the priests but also within
the herd and some in somewhat different
ways within both of them
he says the priest alters the direction
of results
what does he mean here he doesn't again
this is not all a result amount but this
is one of its modalities says every
sufferer instinctively seeks a cause for
his suffering more exactly an agent
somebody who can say that person made me
suffer that person took my opportunities
away from me that person is the reason
why I'm not happy Envy rancor sort of
imaginary revenge
that's what Nietzsche thinks that most
people are actually motivated by
including the priest but more
particularly the people who are down
below the people who are stuck in the
cubicles the people who are taking it
you might say so he says every sufferer
seeks a cause an agent still more
specifically a guilty agent who is
susceptible to suffering who you can
make suffer in return in short some
living thing upon which he can on some
pretext or another vent his effects vent
his feelings vent this desire to to hurt
in return actually or an effigy for the
venting of his aspects that FX sorry
represents the greatest attempt on the
part of the suffering to win relief
Anastasia
there's a feeling that if you can just
vent if you can just say well you know
my life might be crap but there is is
crap - it's not only to feel a little
bit better that's dangerous that's
poisonous nature things and bringing the
high down to the level of the sick the
failure the dead-end the unable to stand
up for itself the simply taking it it's
not actually making their condition
better it's not actually fixing things
so he says this constitutes the
physiological cause of resentiment
ventral isn't like a desire to deaden
pain by means of effects and remember
back to what we were saying just a few
minutes before the philosopher if the
philosopher is actually going to develop
genuine objectivity they have to look at
things through the lenses of multiple
effects effects that are good and
effects that are bad you have to look
look at different effective
interpretations and that's you know sort
of try to put them together it's the
only way that you can actually know this
so he says the suffering are one and all
dreadfully eager and inventive in
discovering occasions for painful
effects they enjoy being mistrustful and
dwelling on nasty deeds and imaginary
slights they scour the entrails of their
past and present for obscure and
questionable occurrences that offer them
the opportunity to revel in tormenting
suspicions and to intoxicate themselves
with a poison of their own malice they
tear apart their oldest wounds they
bleed from long healed scars they make
evildoers out of their friends wives
children and whoever stands closest to
them I suffer someone else must be to
blame for it
HSS this is what the Sheep thinks the
sickly sheep and then the ascetic priest
says to him quite so much sheep someone
must be to blame for it so who's to
blame for it here's the most important
transformation so the ascetic sheep
feels resentment against the strong but
the priest does
turns this backwards against them it
says quite so someone must be to blame
for it
you know that somebody is you you're to
blame for where you are not because
you're a failure or something like that
but because there's something in you
some other kind of failure other than
just not standing up to the strong a
moral failure a religious failure a
spiritual failure so he says this
directs this changes the direction of
resultant now how is it done and
Nietzsche is saying this is done
actually through the control of athletes
so again we have to a little bit more
erasure
what are the fundamental problems that
the priest is dealing on the part of the
the herd and also on his own part well
part of it is resolved enough this you
know urge to say those other people are
the bad ones I'm not the bad one they're
the bad ones I want to hurt them somehow
I can't hurt them physically I can't
actually hurt their stuff I'm going to
call them names I'm going to tear them
down I'm going to whisper behind their
back
I'm going to convince myself that I'm a
good person there are bad people
so that's result another thing that they
have to struggle with feeling of guilt
this goes along with it and sort of like
the flip side of it and then when he
earlier called nausea and we'll also
call depression and how are you going to
deal with these how to purify the person
how to redirect these these forces so
that they don't feel so bad so that
they're not bothered by this stuff which
they are genuinely bothered by by
introducing other effects remedies
and some of these are what he called the
innocent ones and some of the ones that
he calls the guilty ones so let's
actually look through some of these and
let's look at each one of these things
so he says it's a matter of directing
the results amount of the less severely
afflicted sternly back out of themselves
and that way to exploit the bad
instincts of all suffers for the purpose
of self discipline and self surveillance
itself overcoming he says that another
problem going on with this is a feeling
of psychological inhibition
there's nausea this depression it's
almost bound to cease on large masses of
people though they don't diagnose it as
as such thanks both is a dominating
sense of displeasure No how do we
actually deal with this what are the
different needs
well one he says this dominating sense
of displeasure is combat at first by
means that reduce the feeling of life in
general to its lowest point if possible
will and desire are abolished together
all that produce effects and blood is
avoided so this is definitely ascetic
right you'll avoid effects avoid desire
that's one means no love no hate
indifference no revenge no wealth no
work one begs if possible in the women
or as little as possible the result
expressed as he says moral psychological
terms is selflessness or saintliness
sanctification in physiological terms he
calls this hypnotized ation person
hypnotizes themselves in effect the
attempt to win for man an approximation
to what in certain animals is
hibernation so the life of the ascetic
monk for example you know think about
the role of fasting for Christian monks
or the wrote the fact that Buddhist
monks aren't supposed to eat after noon
just limiting the flow of food already
tends to
allow you some Circe's to certain
effects now he goes on and he says
there's some there's some compensations
that come with us it can open the way to
all kinds of spiritual disturbances to
auditory and visual hallucinations to
voluptuous inundations and ecstasy's and
sensuality as in the case of you know
Saint Teresa of ávila it says it goes
without saying the interpretation with
which these with those subject to these
states place upon him has always been
enthusiastic and false as possible but
we should not overlook the note of
utterly convinced gratitude so what goes
along with avoiding aspect is a kind of
compensation with feeling other effects
including feeling pleasure my
diminishing one's pleasure one gives
oneself a different kind of pleasure as
a compensation so that's what he calls
Redemption
what's another possibility what we call
mechanical activity find your software
routine and stick to it
says a different trading against states
of depression which is at any rate
easier mechanical activity mechanical
activity and what goes with it such as
the absolute regularity Punk chalice and
unthinking obedience a mode of life
fixed once and for all
a fully occupied time a certain
permission indeed training for
impersonality for self-forgetfulness
taking you away from the feelings that
you have and just losing yourself and
what it is that you're doing whether it
be sweeping bottling wine mowing the
grass pick whatever you like sowing at
the wounded how thoroughly how subtly
the ascetic priests is known how to
employ these in the struggle against
pain some people are able to lose
themselves in the activity that they
engage
he says another one another more highly
valued means of combating depression is
the preaching of a small pleasure of
heady pleasure pleasure of giving
pleasure make other people happy and
you'll be happy that's another thing
it's counseled in religion by the
priests actually in all sorts of things
isn't it so he says um doing good giving
relieving helping encouraging consoling
praising rewarding love of neighbor the
ascetic priest prescribes fundamentally
and excite and excitement of the
strongest most life-affirming drive the
will to power the pleasure of giving
other people pleasure of helping out
nature things is actually a way of
subtly placing yourself above the other
person and enjoying being able to look
down upon them and say look how good I
am I am able to be good to you who
cannot be good to me
so this happiness of slight superiority
involved in all doing good being useful
helping and rewarding is the most
effective means of consolation he also
talks about
formation of a heard because heard
people like being together they like
thinking the same way they like being in
a group that all sees things the same
way says the sick and sickly
instinctively strive after heard it
organization as a means of shaking off
their dull displeasure and feeling of
weakness so these are all what nietzsche
calls by modern standards innocent means
in the struggle for displeasure these
are all ways in which traditionally
religions and other you know
organizations you know you can think of
you know philosophical groups where
philosophy actually had some sort of
role in society have tried to make
people feel better about these things on
to mark guilt and depression avoid a FX
which will give you pleasure later on
find some mechanical activity to engage
yourself in give other people pleasure
get together with other people now he
says that there are also some more
interesting means that makes is guilty
ones they all know why they all involve
one thing so there's another possibility
to an orgy of feeling employed as the
most effective means of deadening dull
paralyzing protracted pain so how do you
produce an orgy of feeling how do you
bring that about he says to wrench the
human soul from its moorings to immerse
it in terror zeiss flames and raptures
to such an extent that is liberated from
all petty displeasure gloom and
depression by a flash of lightning what
paths lead to this goal which of them do
it most surely it's fundamentally every
great effect has this power provided it
explodes
suddenly so producing the effects itself
what are the anger fear voluptuousness
revenge hope triumph despair cruelty and
the ascetic priest is indeed pressed
into his service indiscriminately the
whole pack of savage hounds and man and
let loose now this one now that always
with the same end in view to awaken men
from their slow melancholy to hunt away
if only for a time they're dull pain and
lingering misery and he says every such
orgy of feeling has to be paid for
afterwards
it makes the sick sicker and that's why
the cure the kind of cure for pain is
but modern standards of guilty think
about our own culture and the ways in
which we give people the possibility to
like have an instant rush of a
particular feeling just get on the on
the web and you can find all different
ways to make yourself feel anger to to
lighten your day all sorts of things
like that I actually myself I know I
like to go at least once a day and look
at sites that will help me to have a
real laugh so I suppose from Nietzsche's
perspective perhaps I would be guilty of
this myself I want something that will
actually like you know force me to laugh
not just you know I'm just kind of there
and hahaha chuckle or something like
that where the effect will in a sense
take me over an almost ecstatic
experience so nature's saying this can
be done with all sorts of other effects
as well and that's one way to deal with
this and that's one thing that the
priest has been doing generally through
religious narratives you should think
however about plenty of other
alternatives you know when people are
getting exuberant over a political
and now the world is going to be so much
brighter and changed or all the world
has gone to crap because this person was
elected are they may be doing what what
Nietzsche is talking about is somebody
offering them that as a panacea against
these these things that have to do with
their actual condition now the last
thing that we have to talk about is the
movement away from the ascetic priests
and the ascetic ideal of the priest to
something different so we have a
historically that's taking place
and we have the priest and we have the
era of religion and this goes all the
way back to prehistory right religions
some of them emerge with history some of
the earliest sex that we have our
religious texts and priests on the way
produces the figure of the philosopher
and from the philosopher really you know
from both the priest and the philosopher
you know if you think about modern
science it didn't have its origin and
people you know saying ah get rid of
religion or something like that it was
actually a lot of religious people who
laid the foundations of modern science
and not just in one religion but it's
interesting too because a lot of the the
important early thinkers had had a lot
of religious convictions some of them
were even priests
I'm going to use this access to know man
to encompass person of science it's a
mindset or does the aesthetic ideal
continue well what is nietzsche talia
she says is a great phrase does in
section 24 says these naysayers and
outsiders of today who are unconditional
on one point their insistence on
intellectual cleanliness these hard
severe abstinent heroic spirits who
constitute the honor of our age all
these pale atheists anti Christians a
moralist needless these skeptics
heretics of the Spirit these last
idealism of knowledge they certainly
believe that there is completely
liberated from the ascetic ideal as
possible these free very free spirits
well you can think about this today some
of these people who get on atheist
websites and they are just like
Crusaders they're not free of the
ascetic ideal third is continuing it
under a different guise they've managed
to throw away the trappings of
institutional religion as a matter of
fact they spend most of their time
occupied with purifying themselves of
institutional religion and trying to
purify the world of it but they just as
much as the priests believe in a
transcendent truth that they are somehow
in touch with in Nietzsche says that
this is at the bottom of science he says
it's a metaphysical faith that underlies
our faith in science and we met of
knowledge today we godless men and anti
meta physicians we still derive our
flame from the fire ignited by a faith
millennial old the Christian faith which
was also Plato's that God is truth that
truth is divine so he says if that's the
case then modern atheism is doing
something really just no different than
ancient religion and medieval religion
was doing it's doing the same thing it's
the same aesthetic ideal
says science never creates values its
relation to the aesthetic ideals by no
means entirely antagonistic it might
even be said to represent the driving
force in the latter's inner development
it opposes and fights not the ideal
itself but only a particular shape of
that ideal it takes the the baton and
starts moving forward you might say
so he says skip on ahead a little bit
more talks about history as well in this
sort of thing
so he says Christianity as a Dogma was
destroyed by its own morality it was
destroyed by what it gave rise to in
part modern science but also in part a
sort of more pure morality and in the
same way Christianity as morality must
perish - and he says we sent we stand on
the threshold of this event and he says
the aesthetic ideal has only one kind of
real enemy capable of harming it the
comedian's of this ideal for they arouse
mistrust of it it's not the man of
science the Dawkins and Hitchens and
people like that you know it in respect
to the atheist versus Christian types of
things it's actually the comedian's of
the ideal he says they arouse mistrust
of it everywhere else that spirit is
strong mighty network without
counterfeit today it does without ideals
of any sort the popular expression for
this abstinence is atheism except for
its relative truth so where do we go
from here
Nietzsche says he says here's the
fundamental problem what meaning would
our whole being possess if it were not
this that in us the will to truth
becomes conscious of itself as a problem
so these people are all inhabited by the
will to
true as sort of unacknowledged unthought
through what about those who can
problematize this those who see that as
a problem for themselves because you
can't just make this into a
philosophical problem what you're going
to handle off on side or a scientific
problem or a religious problem it has to
become an existential problem one which
is posed for the very person who is
asking it what is the will to truth in
me if I don't ask it that way
Nietzsche would say if I only asked it
for others or for human being as such
I'm not truly asking it
so the will to truth becomes conscious
of itself as a problem that's the only
way in which the ascetic ideal can be
overcome